- So, you've been performing for so long,
what were some of your
earliest paid roles?
I always find those interesting.
- Oh sure, paid, I'm trying to think.
The first big job, that I joined SAG
was a McDonalds commercial
that never aired
for soft serve ice cream.
- Oh?
- I think I was 10 or
something and I just like,
licked the cone and then made a face.
(Kelly laughing)
And then went.
It was pretty good, I don't
know why it didn't air.
- Oh my gosh.
- And then, I was outside of Chicago
so we did a lot of industrials
and PSA's and student films.
I did an anti-smoking ad
for the Illinois Department of
Public Health when I was 16.
- I think we actually have a clip of that,
which I'm really excited to
take a look at, personally.
- It's pretty good.
- Okay let's bunch up
and let these folks by.
It's actually a pretty cool school.
The only rule is everybody's gotta smoke.
(bell rings)
Ready?
Here we got languages and stuff.
- Yo tengo que fumar.
- Hey Dude, I am smoke.
- I am smoke.
That was awesome!
I love your comedic
skills though, early on.
You're young for that, that's amazing.
- My commitment to also,
unflattering makeup.
They painted my teeth and
drew circles under my eyes
and I was like, well I
have to go out tonight!
Look at me.
(laughing)